electrodes parallel between complex
numbers and irrational numbers come on
we saw with Irrational's we're good at
working with irrational numbers right so
we know we can combine a rational number
and an irrational number together all
right
some number here some multiple the
square root of anything you like and in
the same way just like with these
irrational numbers we can write complex
numbers as this sort of I called it like
it's oil and water mixture like these
guys kind of stay separate right so I
said something like this this is a
classic way of writing a complex number
by the way just to the side where you've
written this there's another very
frequent way of writing down the complex
number which I'll we're going to get
onto the reasons why next week give me
but for now I want to show you what the
are what the way of writing it is
instead of using a and B frequently the
other pair of per numerals were used to
indicate as things is x and y now for
reasons that will become clear later on
they write the eye first which is like
why is that we'll get to the explanation
for it but now you'll see these just as
frequently and you can see they mean the
same thing they just different labels on
the real part and the imaginary part
good morning can I also clarify when I
talk about the real part and the
imaginary part the real part of Z is a
right and the imaginary part of Z is B
the imaginary part that is not bi it's
like a minor conventional type of thing
but it's important you get when people
say but what's the imaginary part they
mean that number there how many lots of
the imaginary unit you have okay so it's
just a bit right that's actually giving
important later on and of course we need
to make sure we define the most
important part of this where I is the
square root of negative one and that's
our building block okay now last time I
left you with a bit of a conundrum
I said to you something as simple as
arithmetic needs to be we need to be
very careful with it because um you can
come with dangerous things if you're not
careful okay so I'm going to show you
there are four basic operations dinner
in this is right so we're gonna look
through all the Burberry money magazine
and the reason why I'm drawing this
parallel is so that you can see all the
ways we do arithmetic with complex
numbers most of them take their cues
from how we do arithmetic with the
irrational numbers okay
so I think the heading you may have
something you made last time was
addition let's not with that because
it's the simplest right so I'm gonna
define Z equals a plus B I if you've got
more than one complex number flying
around your question or problem you'll
see two different ways that the most
frequent the ladder call them z1 and z2
which is funny enough subscript 1
subscript 2 encrypts it or alternatively
the other most frequent thing you'll see
is they'll call the other complex number
W okay I don't know why so dummy I need
a different pair of numbers to be the
real part and the imaginary part so I'm
just going to arbitrarily call this C
plus D right so ABCD they're just any
old real numbers right that's a real
number that's a real number
all of these constantine have saved our
real numbers okay all right now when you
add when you add in rational numbers
right so if I said to you don't write
this P if I said to you 3 plus root 5
negative 2 plus 4 root 5 and I said can
you add these please like what would you
do that not a particle question I know
it's early
okay you look at the lighthouse and you
combine them in some ways it's like
algebra without the algebra right
because you're like even though root 5
is not an algebraic term we treat it
like one because they can't mix together
yes see you like rational parts
irrational parts and you get your number
up okay and I'm gonna do exactly the
same thing here with additional right
I'm gonna go to so zag plus W I'm gonna
take the real part add them and then I'm
gonna take the imaginary part and Adam
what does that make sense so I'm gonna
go a plus C is my real component right
and then I say well here my imaginary
components over here B plus D and I can
factorize out that imaginary unit okay
so just like with irrational numbers
this is the same and subtraction is just
addition in Reverse so I don't need need
any fancy new rules for your money okay
so addition subtraction so fun looking
good let's move on multiplication now
for this one let's actually do an
example first rather than deal with like
very abstract things and then we'll
write out am a rule a bit later on so
for example I'm gonna steal these
numbers over here okay suppose I had
three plus I am negative 2 plus 4 lyfe
if I were multiplying these comics
numbers together we've actually already
multiplied some complex on this together
but last time we did it they happen to
be conjugates do you remember that they
were the mysterious roots of x squared
plus 2x plus 4 squared plus 2 n possible
so we could take advantage of the
difference of squares there right but I
can't do that here
so what am I gonna do binomial times a
binomial so I want to give me a
suggestion yeah
okay just the normal rules of expansion
if these guys were any terms I've got so
I'm just gonna pair up and I'm going to
multiply through so I'll do three times
both of these times that gives me
negative 6 plus as well I
and then I've got over here plus became
negative 2i plus 4 I swear what do you
think look alright okay now at this
point I hope you stay to get comfortable
with the idea that I squared by
definition is negative 1 I'm going to
encourage you to write I swear rather
than skip that step and go straight to
negative 1 until you're a little more
comfortable and sort of efficient with
these and then over that evaluate so
looking at this now I look at this line
just like before we're going to combine
like terms like this multiplication
question has become an addition question
right so what's the real part in it it's
going to be negative 6 and negative 4
right names it to minus 4 so that gives
me negative 10 and then have a look at
your imaginary component what do you get
left I could factorize if I wanted to
but in this context it's somewhat
meaningless to factorize that n power
because the real part and the imaginary
part are so different to each other it
makes more sense to keep them separate
as we've been doing all this way well
okay now I'm gonna leave it to you to
have a go at just writing this down in
general terms if I had any complex
number Z and any complex number W what
would this how would the Allinger a
panner if I actually multiply these